- Oh, those shoes are great!
- Oh, thanks.
- So wait, this is cool that
you're actually put out,
is it your own type of violin?
- Yes.
- So wait, what makes
your violin different?
- Well, so through the years
I've learned things I like,
and now at this point I
customize all my violins
because classical violins
are very hard to tune.
And especially if you're
in the middle of a show,
or a concert trying to
- They'll de-tune, like
while you're in a show?
- Oh yeah, the pegs will slip
and it's really hard to get.
So I've made these violins
that have these special pegs on them
that allow you to very
quickly adjust, in a second.
I also put some custom
artwork that I actually drew,
and it's etched into the violin.
I'm great at stick figures.
So this
- Oh, that's actually really cool.
- That's the, wow,
that's the original one, but
it's much cuter on the violin.
It's like gold and nice.
But yeah, it's just a really special piece
and it's a beautiful sounding violin.
So I was really happy and I
was so excited our first round
you know, sold out immediately,
and we just barely got a new round in.
So I'm excited about that.
- That's great.
That's what I was gonna,
think of all the like kids
you're inspiring, especially
to start playing violin.
That's so cool.
You're very powerful in that sense.
That's really cool.
I have a question and this is,
I just need to know this answer.
- Okay.
So Shelton and I on "The
Voice" have often argued
the difference between
a fiddle and a violin.
So what do you think the difference
between a fiddle and a violin is?
- It's the way it's played.
- Totally.
Yeah. So we're gonna
edit this out to where
- I was gonna say I have a feeling
that Blake would know that.
- Here's the thing,
no, but I feel like they
also use different strings.
Don't fiddle players use,
like, is it steel strings,
or like I feel like they use different,
I thought I was gonna be right on this.
So I asked,
- [Woman] That's a great question.
I know.
- That's a great, I get
asked that all the time,
but like sometimes I'll play
fiddle music and sometimes
- It's how you play it.
- It's how you play.
- So you're saying he was right.
- I'm sorry, Kelly.
- It's fine
- We're gonna edit this out.
- Yeah.